yes what's the deal well anything from
the economics perspective the news is
mixed because we had bad business
spending durable goods orders were down
especially on the capital good side
which is what everybody watches but the
consumer numbers are all good consumer
confidence the highest since 2007 new
home sales higher we're seeing some more
gasoline related boost to the economy
going into 2015 durable goods
notoriously volatile if people often
don't take too much stuff from that
number well it is volatile but when you
get five of the last six months down for
capital goods orders you have to figure
the business spending is slowing a
little bit that may be because of the
strong dollar or in the case of
Caterpillar which reported earnings
today because oil prices are down so
capital spending on exploration and
mining is down look at a chart of the SP
and I look and see that you know come
January 22nd which was last Thursday
which was ECB day we've had a really not
very strong S&P we've seen a slow
decline ever since then I have to wonder
isn't it supposed to be good for stocks
and this was to inflate asset prices and
I said it was the opposite well I mean
if you look at the other fundamental
news today on the earnings front it is
not good and not uniformly not good but
a lot of the big companies that with
numbers are not reporting good numbers
so when investors wake up and see that
they're not very happy about it and
let's keep in mind something else that
has nothing to do directly with the
markets and that's that we had this big
blizzard that wasn't right but that a
lot of people are still home today so
yes we are seeing a big move yes we are
seeing some fundamental reasons behind
that big move but you also have to
remember a lot of people are probably
not participating in this market so you
could have some market distortions with
this lower than usual volume this was
already set up before we even came in
for the US trading day let's not forget
what we saw overseas the Shanghai
Composite down nine tenths of one
percent because Chinese companies
industrial profits dropped eight percent
the most since 2011 the anecdotal that
we got from companies reporting earnings
today caterpillar for instance saying
that construction equipment sales in
China will be lower this year not
helping this sense of pessimism of
regarding the global economy there was
also in the foreign exchange market a
lot of whipsaw trading in the Swiss
franc that got people wondering did the
Swiss National Bank intervene and buy
Euros and if so what does this mean
about their policy of gee pegging the
currency what what kind of game are they
playing it just adds to the violence
okay but is this whole conversation
going to be completely null and void
when everybody gets back to work
tomorrow they look at the market dip and
say great buying opportunity
I love the US economy again well that's
been the history now everybody is
calling as they have been for three
years for some sort of market correction
a ten percent drop to consolidate gains
and then move forward we don't get that
so you really don't know cuz people
think it's gonna happen but they don't
know what the trigger has been and we
haven't been able to get to it so far
but it's interesting isn't Marco [ __ ]
Michael che wool of market fill asset
management said that he actually thinks
the correlation between US stocks and
the dollar will actually continue which
sort of makes this sell-off even more
confusing into 70s point perhaps by the
dip opportunity you wonder though what
this all means for the Federal Reserve
they are meeting this week and they will
make an announcement no one's expecting
any kind of change but does it push
their timetable for an eventual
increment is this really a big enough
move for the Fed to care should the Fed
be watching things this closely and
change their behavior just because a few
equities doesn't pay attention to what
the equity markets are doing and they
really aren't looking at the growth
figures so much right now because what
they're seeing is reasonably good growth
and very strong job growth they're
watching the inflation numbers and
that's the question that the dollar
leads to and exchange rates and oil
prices do we see declining inflation
that might keep them on hold we'll be
watching their statement tomorrow see
what they say about prices and not to go
off in yet another direction about what
happens tomorrow part of its gonna have
to do with the Fed part of its gonna
have to do with Apple remember after the
close today not that it's gonna set the
tone for everything but look at what
Microsoft is doing to the entire tech
sector today in terms of what the stock
prices are doing what Apple says after
the bell is gonna be important for the
tone tomorrow right that doesn't feel
like whatever apple says gets turned
into a positive so buy this for a while
that was a that was the trend but it
will have a sort of window into the
consumer which mike has I'm watching
Stephanie's bear is there it looks like
an Apple watch would fit I got my job
going on that's enough no need for an
out who needs a watch he have a smart
phone
continue to watch this market of guys
thank you so much Mike's car and Julie
we appreciate it we'll continue to watch
we have the SP now at 2023